en fait ça a commencé comme ça tu meurs
construire un sens un son unique au des
deux bises pour réaffirmer haut et fort
leur présence allemande et pop
au moment où est-ce que tu monde
pourrait s'attendre à ce que ce soit
finie mais nous on veut encore remettre
de cette catastrophe le la catastrophe
pour les des daubes is a été le départ
de yes we can
un des membres importants du groupe est
aussi acteur un coup dur pour ceux dont
la carrière allait rondement depuis six
ans avec au compteur une centaine de
spectacles ici et en europe et deux
albums à ébranler
je pense que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a six cordes
aujourd'hui le groupe qui chante en
français et en anglais dans un même
souffle tourner la page et lance un
disque qui s'appelle dead ou si vous
préférez mourir pour mieux renaître le
dénominateur commun de tout ceci est une
franchise bilan n'a été dans les
chansons si j'ai good est agressif je
vois pas je vois pas de dose et je peux
que m'excuser king avec des artistes
comme alaclair ensemble coriace et qui
quitte la scène musicale et pop
québécoise est en pleine effervescence
et c'est sans compter la rhd dont la
pierre que les femmes savent lancée et
la toute première chanson et pop encore
paul à se hisser au numéro un des
palmarès les des daubes is se
réjouissent de cet intérêt pour le hip
hop ça me stimule moi je marche beaucoup
à ce genre des ce genre de sentiment
d'urgence la cible de voir en fait que
comme il commence à avoir un petit peu
plus d'ouverture jean méhault
boli festival même s'il ya une ouverture
pour l'aider de bise il reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir
on est la seule place en amérique du
nord ce trou elop a pas avoir de radio
spécialisée en hip-hop avec leurs
nouvelles chansons
les des deux bises partent en tournée à
la reconquête de la planète et pop
julie jocelyne boudreault radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
demain